they lined up to watch it high-profile
people high emotions and a highly
divisive debate at the border right now
you're in a cheering room it's my time
don't blame the men and women wearing a
uniform doing the best they can
it's outrageous this is political
theater at its best recent reports have
described overcrowding and unsanitary
conditions in detention centers this
rising star in the Democratic Party says
she witnessed that up close and so when
these women tell me that they were put
into a cell and that their sink was not
working and we tested the sink ourselves
and the sink was not working and they
were told to drink out of a toilet bowl
I believe them
I believe these women I believed the
canker sores that I saw in their mouths
because they were only allowed to be fed
on nutritious food I believed them when
they said they were sleeping on concrete
floors for two months I believed them
and what was worst about this mr.
chairman was the fact that there were
American flags hanging all over these
facilities that children being separated
from their parents in front of an
American flag the congresswoman has
pushed her own party to do more on the
issue of child separation and she's
captured the imagination of younger more
diverse voters here her office is
decorated with their hopeful messages of
support immigration could be a deciding
factor in 2020 her colleague broke down
as she recounted her experience Mr
Speaker we do have a crisis at our
border it is one of morality as we have
seen this current strategy unfold
intentional and cruelly created by the
Trump administration dead set on sending
a hate-filled message that those seeking
refuge are not welcome in America in our
America the Republicans insist the
crisis is at the border not in
government facilities
I've been to the border multiple times
and it didn't just come recently putting
on a show in front of fences for the
media it's come to over a career of
trying to figure out how to secure the
border and do our job my chief of staff
went to the border this last Saturday
down to clint to go to the facility
after hearing all the horror stories my
chief of staff had a very different
first experience in terms of what he saw
in terms of the cleanliness the
facilities in terms of Border Patrol
trying to do its job trying to make sure
that people are taking care of after a
long hard journey for Mexico making sure
they do have potable water including
having water containers right outside
the very cells where we were told that
they didn't have water to drink having
the toothpaste the food the diapers the
things that are necessary
the vice president Mike Pence headed to
McAllen Texas to try and counter claims
of cruelty as he took a tour migrants
tried to sleep on makeshift beds two
worlds colliding a small trolley of
nappies for him to inspect children
watching on then face-to-face with a man
who could decide their futures this is
very tough stuff to see families that
are swept up in this crisis on our
southern border but I must tell you that
different for what we hear from many of
the critics I couldn't be more impressed
with the compassionate work that our
custom do Border Protection are doing
here at this facility
this Sunday federal agents will receive
raids in ten cities to arrest two
thousand undocumented immigrants these
families can only watch and wait
Hoddy the alleged Sky News Washington